[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
am 12 oktober 2001 verschwindet Rudolf
Rupp ohne eine Spur zu hinterlassen ein
Vermisstenfall der zum Mordfall wird
nach langen erfolglosen Ermittlungen
konzentriert sich die Staatsanwaltschaft
auf das engste Umfeld des Bauern seine
Frau seine Töchter und der Freund einer
der Töchter sollen ihn erschlagen haben
und seinen Leichnam an die Hofhunde
verfüttert haben dieses bizarre Detail
elektrisiert die Öffentlichkeit
2005 werden die vier wegen Totschlags
bzw Beihilfe und Unterlassung verurteilt
Case closed Fall gelöst danke fürs
zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal
natürlich nicht ihr kennt uns doch da
gibt es natürlich noch einiges zu
erzählen denn dieser Fall nimmt eine
dramatische Wende als ein ganz
besonderer Zeuge auftaucht auftaucht
trifft es ja auch sehr gut oder absolut
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir
und ich bin Stefan Netzeband und Mirko
erzählt uns jetzt die ganze Geschichte
noch einmal ganz von vorne bitte lieber
Mirko Ronald Rupp genannt Rudi lebt mit
seiner Frau Hermine und seinen 15 bzw
16-Jährigen Töchtern Andrea und Manuela
auf einem ziemlich heruntergekommenen
Hof am Rande von heinrichsheim in
Oberbayern zum Haushalt gehört auch
Matthias e der 18-Jährige Freund und
Verlobte von Manuela
heinrichsheim wiederum ist ein Stadtteil
von Neuburg hat sich aber trotz
Eingemeindung seinen dörflichen
Charakter erhalten man kennt sich viele
Familien leben hier seit Generationen
und man redet wahrscheinlich mindestens
so viel übereinander wie Miteinander mit
Rudolf Rupp jedenfalls reden viele nicht
so gern er trinkt oft über den Durst und
wird dann streitsüchtig und aggressiv er
ist Stammgast im Wirtshaus genauer
gesagt im Vereinsheim des BSV Neuburg
oft besucht er es direkt nach der Arbeit
im Stall also wirklich direkt nach der
Arbeit im Stall so wird es berichtet
Gummistiefeln mit Latzhose und den
entsprechenden sagen wir eben
steigergeruch dürfte seiner Beliebtheit
nicht gerade zuträglich gewesen sein
vermutlich nicht überhaupt hat die ganze
Familie keinen besonders guten Ruf der
Hof ist verfallen und gilt vielen als
Schandfleck Matthias der Verlobte von
Manuela ist alkoholkrank die Töchter
gehen auf eine sonder bzw Förderschule
wenn Sie den gehen Vater Rudi gilt als
Familien Tyrann und manche meinen gar er
würde seine Töchter missbrauchen am 12
oktober 2001 fährt Rudolf wieso oft in
seinem Mercedes auf den Parkplatz des
Vereinsheims setzt sich an seinen
üblichen Platz und beginnt zu trinken
acht Weißbier und eine Schachtel
Zigaretten stehen am Ende auf seiner
Rechnung Rudolf Rupp lässt Anschreiben
als der wird schließlich die Kneipe
schließt er geht zu seinem Mercedes
rammt bei der Ausfahrt vom Parkplatz
beinahe ein Blumenkübel und wird nie
mehr lebend gesehen
8 Weißbier das ist schon eine
ordentliche Menge ja das schafft man nur
mit viel Übung man schätzt dass er
ungefähr 2,5 Promille gehabt haben muss
als er sich auf den Heimweg macht der
wird gibt später an er habe Rupp
angeboten ihn nach Hause zu bringen der
aber habe abgelehnt na klar kann ja
jeder überhaupt also wenn jemand mit so
einem Pegel ins Auto steigt ein drängt
sich natürlich der Verdacht auf dass
irgendwas mit ihm geschehen sein könnte
denn irgendwas muss geschehen sein am
nächsten Tag nämlich geht seine Frau zur
Polizei und meldet Rudolf Rupp als
vermisst er sei in der Nacht nicht nach
Hause gekommen natürlich gehen alle von
einem Verkehrsunfall aus allerdings
finden sich auf der ganzen kurzen
Strecke zwischen dem Wirtshaus und dem
Hof der Rupps weder ein Auto fragt noch
sonst irgendwelche Spuren eines Unfalls
der Vater und sein Mercedes sind wie vom
Erdboden verschluckt als die üblichen
Suchaktionen der Polizei erfolglos
bleiben beginne die Leute sich selbst
einen Reim darauf zu machen da ist doch
was faul und die Rupps haben sowieso
schon immer so komisch gewirkt wir
wissen nicht wie die Gerüchte begonnen
haben vielleicht hat jemand sowas gesagt
wie nein die werden froh sein dass sie
in den alten los sind vielleicht meinte
dann jemand ja ich würde sogar verstehen
wenn sie da ein bisschen nachgeholfen
haben und ein paar Tage später ist dann
vielleicht schon ein ich habe gehört
dass sie da ein bisschen nachgeholfen
haben draußen geworden und irgendwann
macht möglicherweise jemand einen
ziemlich schlechten Scherz bestimmt
haben Sie ihn an die Hunde verfüttert
haha woraus schließlich hey hast du
schon gehört die sollen ihn an die Hunde
verfüttert haben wurde wie gesagt das
wissen wir nicht das ist nur ein Versuch
und selbst zu erklären wie so etwas
funktioniert kann je länger Rudolf Rupp
vermisst wird desto wilder werden die
Spekulationen und aus den Spekulationen
werden Vermutungen aus den Vermutungen
beinahe Gewissheit
es gab keinen Verkehrsunfall Rudolf Rupp
ist wie so oft sturzbetrunken aber
ansonsten heil zu Hause angekommen dort
kam es zum Streit wahrscheinlich ging es
um den Verlobten mit dem der rudija nie
gut zurechtgekommen ist aus dem Streit
entwickelt sich ein Handgemenge und am
Ende ist Rudolf Tod um den Tod zu
vertuschen zerstückelt die Familie die
Leiche und verbuddelt die Leichenteile
oder in einer besonders krassen Version
verfüttert sie an die Hofhunde
beinahe dreieinhalb Jahre gären die
Gerüchte vor sich hin während die
Polizei bei der Suche nach dem
Familienvater nicht weiterkommt die
Geschichten von Mord oder Totschlag
scheinen immer plausibler im Jahr 2004
klopft die Polizei mit einem
Durchsuchungsbefehl an der Tür heraus
die Beamten finden den Hof in
verwahrlosten Zustand vor
Gerümpel und Müll liegen überall auf dem
Gelände zahllose Hunde streunen auf dem
Grundstück umher Ehefrau Töchter
Verlobter werden zum Verhör mitgenommen
während der Hof durchsucht wird
erfolglos das können wir schon mal
verraten es finden sich keinerlei
Hinweise auf ein Verbrechen keine
Leichenteile keine Blutspuren nichts
auch der Mercedes des Vaters wird nicht
gefunden dafür ist die Vernehmung der
Familie umso ergiebiger die wichtigste
Frage lautet anfangs ob Rudolf Rupp in
Jena Nacht vielleicht doch nach Hause
gekommen ist und die Rupps knicken ein
ja der Vater sei nach Hause gekommen
nach und nach und in getrennt
voneinander durchgeführten Befragungen
entlocken die Beamten der Familie die
Geschichte ja es hat einen Streit
gegeben ja auch ein Handgemenge ja der
Rudolf sei dabei zu Tode gekommen
Werbung
wir kriegen ja immer wieder Fragen von
euch rein was ihr denn eigentlich
abgesehen von Podcast zu machen was wir
so privat anstellen ob wir da auch
andere Interessensgebiete haben und ich
sage ganz klar nein in meiner Freizeit
verbringe ich gerne viel Zeit vom
Fernseher irgendwie True Crime Dokus
Krimis etc ich bin ein ganz großer Doku
Fan und Marktes halt wenn ich irgendwie
nach einem stressigen Tag nach Hause
komme oder aus dem Studio gehe und mit
einem Abend irgendwie mich von der
schönen Doku berieseln lasse oder sogar
ich gebe zu auch ein bisschen Trash TV
schauen ja bei mir ist das Problem ein
bisschen dass ich überhaupt gar keine
richtigen Sender habe das heißt ich kann
halt wirklich nur über Apps oder
Mediatheken gucken und wenn ich halt so
richtig Fernsehprogramm will muss ich
halt zu meiner Tante rüber in die
Wohnung bei mir ist das eigentlich ich
habe einen Fernseher zum Glück ja ich
muss nicht zu meiner Tante oder zu
meinem Onkel gehen ich habe einen
Fernseher hast du richtig mit Sendern so
richtig mit seiner bei mir ist halt nur
das Problem dass es dann manchmal Streit
was heißt Streit aber dann gibt's halt
manchmal Diskussion darüber was man denn
gerade sehen will ja der eine möchte
dass der andere das und du geht es hin
und her also der berühmte Streit um die
Fernbedienung genau den könnt ihr euch
aber ersparen denn mit o2 TV könnt ihr
ganz einfach übers Internet schauen da
findet ihr über 130 TV-Sender in HD und
ihr könnt auch bis zu 100 Stunden an
Live-Sendungen Serien und so weiter
einfach aufnehmen oder Filme anhalten
und später weiterschauen und das gute
ist Mirko ihr müsst euch nicht mehr
prügeln was ihr gucken wollt denn mit o2
TV funktionieren bis zu vier
unterschiedliche Geräte gleichzeitig und
das nicht nur zu Hause sondern auch
unterwegs und das beste o2 TV gibt es
jetzt sogar inklusive Netflix das ist
natürlich ein super Angebot denn ich bin
ja ein riesengroßer Rick und Morty Fan
und auch die Office das sind beides
Serien die bei mir in meiner Netflix
watch schließt ganz ganz oben stehen ich
werde immer in meinem Freundeskreis ein
bisschen gehänselt dass ich noch nie
diese US-Serie shameless gesehen habe
die gab es aber bisher noch nicht auf
Netflix seit dem 1 September haben sie
alle 11 Staffeln drauf geballert und das
sage ich dir am nächsten Wochenende wird
da richtig durchgesucht also falls ihr
die Serie auch noch nicht kennt als es
eure Chance guckt ihr euch mal unbedingt
an also Bucht jetzt o2 TV für günstige
9,99 € im Monat und erhalte 12 Monate
Netflix geschenkt geht dafür einfach auf
o2.de/go2/ Tatort also o2.de/got
/ Tatort TA t o r t und sichert euch mit
o2 TV und Netflix das Beste aus live
Fernsehen und Streaming als Paket alle
Infos und den link zum Angebot den
findet ihr auch in unseren Show Notes
und ihr wisst ja Leute o2 Kendo
Werbung Ende die ermittlerrekonstruieren
anhand dieser Aussagen besser gesagt
dieser Geständnisse schließlich
folgenden tatjagang Matthias Ehe habe
Rudolf Rupp im Treppenhaus mit einem
Vierkantholz ins Genick geschlagen die
Töchter und die Mutter hätten ihn dabei
angefeuert dann habe die Frau Rupp ihren
Mann mit einer Latte auf den Kopf
geschlagen die Töchter hätten auf den am
Boden liegenden eingetreten dann hätten
sie den wehrlosen aber noch lebenden
Rudolf Rupp in den Keller geschafft wo
Matthias eh und seine Verlobte Manuela
mit einem Hammer seine Schläfer
eingeschlagen hätten ein wildes Gemenge
es ist gerade im Nachhinein schon
bemerkenswert wie dich die Erzählung der
Rupps an den Gerüchten im Dorf dran sind
denn sie bestätigen ja selbst das
gruseligste Detail ja sie hätten den
Rudi zerhackt gekocht und dann an die
hofrunde verfüttert Matthias Egge steht
die Arme und Beine des Opfers abgetrennt
den Bauch aufgeschnitten
Organe entnommen und das Blut mit einem
Margarine Becher abgeschöpft und in
einen Eimer gegossen zu haben den Kopf
habe er gekocht um ihn besser zerteilen
zu können
anschließend hätten sie die Leichenteile
an die auf dem Hof lebenden Dobermänner
Bullterrier und Schäferhunde verfüttert
weil ich fast schon man kann sich fragen
warum die jetzt offiziell Verdächtigen
dass alles gestanden haben so spät oder
mehr als drei Jahre sind sie angeblich
damit durchgekommen und es finden sich
auch keinerlei Hinweise für ihre Schuld
sie hätten einfach nur alles bestreiten
müssen und niemand hätte ihn etwas
anhaben können also schon fast ein
perfektes Verbrechen und das sollte
eigentlich stutzig machen die Rucks sind
ganz sicher keine kriminellen Genies
Gutachter attestieren allen vier
Beschuldigten sogar eine minder Begabung
die IQs der Töchter liegen weit unter
dem Durchschnitt die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation spricht in
solchen Fällen von leichter
Intelligenzminderung Menschen die davon
betroffen sind erreichen im
Erwachsenenalter ungefähr das
Intelligenzniveau eines neuen bis
zwölfjährigen Kindes sie können einen
selbstständiges und erfülltes Leben
führen leiden aber ein
Gedächtnisschwäche und
Kommunikationsschwierigkeiten sind
häufig sozial und emotional unreif und
in der Regel leicht manipulierbar aha
genau am dritten februar 2004 soll die
Familie vor Ort den Tathergang
nachstellen Kripo Beamte stehen als
Laiendarsteller zur Verfügung das ganze
wird mit Videokameras aufgezeichnet in
der Spiegel TV-Reportage vier Mörder und
ein Todesfall aus dem Jahr 2012 kann man
Ausschnitte aus diesen Videos sehen auf
den Aufnahmen sieht man immer wieder wie
einer der Polizisten die Leitung
übernimmt er scheint die Rupps immer
wieder in konkrete Aussagen zu bringen
man sieht wie Andrea die zu dem
Zeitpunkt erst 17 ist mit mehreren
Beamten im Treppenhaus den Ablauf des
Streits zwischen ihren Eltern
nacherzählen soll
zwei Beamte simulieren dabei die
Bewegungen der beiden Eltern
Andrea wird nervös und aufgelöst zieht
immer wieder an einer Zigarette es gibt
einige Ungereimtheiten in ihrer
Erzählung zum Beispiel wo genau der
Streit im Treppenhaus stattgefunden
haben soll oder wie genau Rudolf dann am
Fuß der Treppe gelegen haben soll wenn
Andreas sich unsicher ist legt ihr der
leitende Polizist setze vor denen sie
einfach nur zustimmen soll mehrfach
bricht Andrea in Tränen aus der leitende
Polizist umarmt sie um sie zu beruhigen
ja man hat an mehreren Stellen beinahe
den Eindruck als wollten sie es den
Ermittlern recht machen und dennoch da
stehen sie belasten sich selbst und
untereinander belasten einander
gegenseitig erzählen sich in allen
Details vom Tod Schlag und der
Beseitigung der Leiche und die
Ungereimtheiten und Widersprüche kann
man mit der langen Zeit erklären die
seit der Tat vergangen ist und mit der
allseits bekannten und zuver Möglichkeit
von Zeugenaussagen im Allgemeinen und so
sieht es auch das Gericht am 13 mai 2005
verurteilt das Landgericht Ingolstadt
die Ehefrau von Rudolf Rupp eine der
Töchter und Matthias e zu je achteinhalb
Jahren Haft wegen Totschlags mangels
Beweisstücken oder anderen
Zeugenaussagen beruft sich das Gericht
ausschließlich auf die Geständnisse der
Angeklagten die sie längst widerrufen
haben aber das spielt für das Gericht
keine Rolle genauso wenig wie die
entlastenden Indizien die von der
Verteidigung vorgebracht werden zum
Beispiel
Tagebucheintragungen der Töchter indem
sie ihren Vater den sie angeblich so
hasten dass sie noch auf ihn eintraten
als er schon am Boden lag anfliehen zu
ihnen zurückzukehren dass sie ihn so
vermissen ja die könnten natürlich aus
eiskalter Berechnung geschrieben worden
sein um von der eigenen Schuld
abzulenken aber naja eiskalte Berechnung
das passt irgendwie nicht zu den beiden
Töchtern
an die Urteile sind erstmal
rechtskräftig die Angeklagten kommen bzw
bleiben inhaft
und dann am 10 märz 2009 die Rupps und
Matthias eh sitzen zu diesem Zeitpunkt
seit fünf Jahren in Haft taucht Rudolf
Rupp wieder auf buchstäblich
an diesem Tag werden oberhalb der
Staustufe Bergheim etwa 5 km von
heinrichsheim entfernt zwei Autos aus
der Donau geborgen eines der Fahrzeuge
ist der Mercedes von Rudolf Rupp als das
Fahrzeug noch über dem Wasser hängt
bricht die Windschutzscheibe an der
Fahrerseite und die Leiche des Vaters
gleitet ins Wasser zurück
nachdem die skelettierte Leiche geborgen
wurde ist schnell klar dass Rudolf Rupp
nicht erschlagen worden sein kann denn
es sind keine Verletzungen feststellbar
und dass die ganze Sache mit dem
zerteilen und verfüttern nicht stimmen
kann ja das versteht sich dann schon ein
bisschen von selbst es gibt Spuren von
Fisch fraß aber das ist ja nun mal eine
ganz andere und echt verständliche
Sachen die genaue Todesursache und der
Ablauf der Geschehnisse in jeder Nacht
können nicht mehr ermittelt werden eine
relativ plausible Möglichkeit ist dass
Rudolf Rupp sich das Leben genommen hat
eigentlich sollte der Podcast die Enten
mit dem Satz die Angeklagten werden
umgehend entlassen und ihn wird eine
Haft Entschädigung zugesprochen aber
leider nein obwohl praktisch sämtliche
Feststellungen des Gerichts und alle
Aussagen in den widerrufen den
Geständnissen eindeutig falsch sind
verweigert das Gericht ein
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren wie kann denn
das bitte angehen tja die Begründung
lautet salopp zusammengefasst
Rudolf Rupp ja trotzdem tot sei man
keine Zweifel daran habe dass die
Angeklagten daran schuld sein und es
nicht so wichtig sei wie sie ihn nun
genau getötet und seine Leiche entsorgt
hätten das ist Wahnsinn oder zum Glück
gibt es Oberlandesgericht München den
wiederaufnahmeanträgen der Verteidigung
schließlich doch noch statt am 25
Februar 2011 werden die Verurteilten vor
dem Landgericht Landshut freigesprochen
na ja ein Freispruch zweiter Klasse
wegen Mangels an Beweisen obwohl jede
plausible Tat Hypothese fehlt obwohl die
zweifelhaften Befragungsmethoden der
Polizei längst öffentlich bekannt sind
glaubt das Gericht weiterhin dass die
Familie oder der Verlobte etwas mit dem
Tod von Rudolf Rupp zu tun hätten sie
müssten nur lediglich deshalb frei
gesprochen werden da man nicht genau
nachweisen könne wer von ihnen ihn wie
getötet habe das ist eine krasse Nummer
die Rupps und Matthias eh sitzen
insgesamt zwei Drittel ihre Haftstrafe
ab dann werden sie wirklich frei
gelassen sie bzw ihre Anwälte Stellen
Anträge auf Haftentschädigung die
abgelehnt oder nur teilweise gewährt
werden Begründung durch ihre falschen
Geständnisse seien sie schließlich
selbst schuld an ihrer Verurteilung
am Ende bleibt natürlich eine große
Frage wie kann denn so etwas bitte
passieren wie können Ermittler und
Gerichte so falsch liegen und so
schlecht arbeiten und entgegen aller
Beweise ihre Fehler dann nicht mal
einsehen tja wenn man so eine Story hört
dann ist natürlich die erste Reaktion
Empörung absolut man denkt sich sofort
dass sie alle völlig unfähig gewesen
sein müssen oder noch schlimmer bösartig
oder was weiß ich für eine Verschwörung
dahinter stecken könnte und so weiter
und so fort und natürlich bin ich davon
überzeugt dass mir so etwas nie
passieren könnte ja Mirko tut mir leid
dass du es auf diesem Wege erfährst aber
das ist vermutlich falsch okay um eins
klar zu stellen wir waren nicht dabei
wir können nur vermuten bis zu diesem
Justizskandal gekommen sein könnte und
wir wollen ganz sicher nichts
entschuldigen oder klein reden aber ich
denke doch dass es wichtig ist sich
darüber Gedanken zu machen wie so etwas
passiert statt einfach nur die sind doch
alle unfähig zu rufen ich denke eine
Rolle könnte der Druck gespielt haben
man wollte das Verschwinden von Rudolf
Rupp unbedingt aufklären also ich kann
ein Stück weit schon verstehen die
Polizei die Ermittler mussten ja mit all
diesen wilden Gerüchten und
Anschuldigungen umgehen auf der einen
Seite und was man auch berücksichtigen
muss glaube ich bei dieser Art
suggressive Fragen zu stellen ist dass
man das ja mit nicht besonders hoch
intelligenten Menschen zu tun hatte
vielleicht will man in diesem Befragung
dann auch helfen Ihnen ein bisschen auf
die Sprünge helfen damit das Verfahren
voran kommt so könnte ich mir das
einigermaßen zurechtlegen man hat halt
versucht
ihnen so ein bisschen die Ideen
vorzugeben und Ihnen mit diesen Ideen
unter die Arme zu greifen denn wenn sie
unschuldig gewesen wären dann würden sie
ja nicht mitspielen bei diesem ganzen
Prozedere ja das eine gute Spur noch mal
eine Kuh warum haben die sich überhaupt
so schwer selber belastet da kann man
sagen wahrscheinlich waren sie einfach
überfordert die saßen lange in
Untersuchungshaft sie waren eh
verschrien in diesem Dorf dann wurden
sie immer wieder getrennt befragt
wussten vielleicht nicht was der andere
gesagt hat und vielleicht wurde ihnen da
auch schon so ein bisschen die
Geschichte in den Mund gelegt alles
wovon sie glaubten dass sie Beamten das
dann eben so hören wollen sie wollten es
vielleicht einfach richtig machen ja und
sicherlich haben sich die Beamten
während der ganzen Ermittlungen auch in
diesem Fall immer mehr reingesteigert
vielleicht auch eine ganz normale
menschliche Schwäche vor der wir alle
nicht gefeit sind der sogenannte
Konfirmation ist oder die
bestätigungsverzerrung wir alle haben
sozusagen Scheuklappen auf wenn wir von
etwas überzeugt sind dann neigen wir
dazu nur solche Informationen
wahrzunehmen die diese Überzeugung
bestätigen ja und im Umkehrschluss
landen wir dann auch Informationen aus
die uns da nicht so gut zu passen ja und
wenn mehrere Leute an so einem Fall
arbeiten dann bestät die sich natürlich
gegeneinander und damit hält jeder
Objektivität und Sorgfalt der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen einfach hinten
unter und wenn man Zweifel auftauchen
dann überlegt man sich vielleicht
zweimal ob man den anderen damit jetzt
auf die Nerven geht ja auch
Kollegialität kann einen Beitrag zu
Fehlentscheidungen leisten also ihr
merkt wir könnten hier immer weiter
sinnieren der Fall ist auf jeden Fall
total faszinierend von dem Verhalten der
Familie und der Ermittler wer sich dafür
interessiert wie es zu sowas kommen kann
der sollte sich unbedingt auch die
Episode der Tote Bauer Rupp des Podcast
sprechen wir über Mord von SWR2 anhören
das mal als geschwisterlicher als
kollegialer Hinweis da kommt nämlich
auch der ehemalige Bundesrichter Thomas
Fischer sehr ausgewogen und spannend
zitiert zu Wort zu diesem Thema und wer
mehr über den Fall an sich wissen will
dem können wir die Spiegel TV Reportage
4 Mörder und ein Todesfall ans Herz
legen danke auf jeden Fall fürs Zuhören
wir würden uns sehr freuen wenn ihr uns
weiterempfehlt und eine Bewertung für
uns da lasst und die Glocke aktiviert
und vor allem natürlich wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid
bis dahin euer Mirko und euer Stefan